[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Levi
William EagleFeather,
the founder of the
IronEagleFeather Project,
is a Sicangu Lakota from the
Rosebud Sioux Reservation
in Rosebud, South Dakota.
At age four, Levi was forcibly
removed from his family
and adopted to a Nebraska
farming family, a practice
quite common at that time.
No longer having access to
his community or his culture,
he ran away at age 15.
By age 17, he had joined
the US Marine Corps, where
he served from 1974 to 1978.
Experiencing a cultural
reawakening in his 20s,
he returned to his
Lakota roots and began
relearning the history,
ceremony, and tradition that
is the bedrock of
the Lakota lifestyle.
During this time, he worked
as a union carpenter, then
an electrician,
raised five children,
and was foster parent
to many at-risk youth.
In the '90s, he made
it his life work
to reintroduce the Lakota
way by utilizing the emerging
cultural revitalization
movement.
He used the tools he learned
from studying psychology
in college and his time
spent in the Western world
in combination with the ceremony
and tradition of his people
to work with at-risk
youth and adults
on and off the reservation.
He has worked in crisis centers,
group homes, and foster care
settings, developing programs
for more than 20 years.
He has conducted spiritual
camps and developed workshops
using cultural
activities for decades.
It's now my pleasure
to introduce you
to Levi EagleFeather.
Levi.
[APPLAUSE]
All of you know that
climate change is real.
I also know from my
visit here at your campus
that you hold many of
the same values and ideas
that a lot of us Lakotas hold.
And it shows in the way
that you treat your people
and how supportive
you are of all
the people within your group,
your culture, your business.
All of these core principles
and understandings
come from our shared
need of each other.
And you found that.
And it's a shared need that
we need to interact and find
our optimum selves.
As a son, a father,
and a grandfather,
like you, I know we all care
for our parents, our children,
our partners, and much more.
We share those same feelings.
I'm here to share with you my
understanding, some of which
is shared by other grassroots
Lakotas, where I'm from,
of how Lakota thought and life
practices direct our thinking
and reasoning where I'm from.
One of the things that directs
our thoughts and our reasoning
is prayer.
In Lakota, we look at songs
as holding these prayers.
I'm going to start
my presentation
with one of those prayers.
And I'll explain to you
a little bit about it.
The words are very simple.
It is, "Grandfather"-- as
some of you might think,
it might be God--
"I'm having a hard time.
Help me."
Very simple.
Most of our prayers in
Lakota are very simple.
I have divided my
presentation into four parts.
Each part I will be introducing
with one of those prayers.
And each song I will be
explaining when I sing it.
When we think about who
we are and what we are,
in Lakota there's a
common-held belief--
we may not state it
this way all the time,
but it's a common-held
belief that all of us,
everything, is made of
the metals, minerals,
and liquids of the
Earth, and that we
get our energy from the sun.
When we think of
it this way, it's
inescapable to recognize that
the Earth would be our mother.
We're made at our
DNA level, our forms,
of the metals, minerals,
and liquids, of the Earth.
In the same token, when we
get our energy from the sun,
we would think of the sun as
being male, or Father Sky.
And those things are natural
and very easy to understand.
The ceremonies and rituals
passed down by my relatives
not only helped me
understand my responsibility
to include the Earth when
I think about my health
and welfare.
It's like thinking
of your mother.
It's a natural process.
And as an adult, as a
son and as a father,
it's my responsibility to learn
as much about these things
as I can, simply so that I can
pass them on to my children
and to my grandchildren.
OK?
But let me remind
you, before I get
started, that I was raised
away from my people.
I was taken from my people.
So I grew up in Western society
without any of these ceremonies
and rituals.
I think what's important
to non-Lakota to people
to understand when I bring
this message that I bring
is that as a human being, not
as anything else, but as a human
being, I am the same
as you in the fact
that I was able to learn
this culture, Lakota culture.
OK?
A lot of times, people,
we get into these talks
about who we are and
what we are and DNA.
And somehow, it happens that
from DNA, we become Lakota.
But actually being
a Lakota in our way
is about being good allies,
good relatives, good parents,
all of the same
things that you hold.
But that is our focus.
OK?
It's not to go out and
be the best at everything
else other than just being
who we are as human beings.
But these ceremonies and
rituals as we get into them
and we began to
teach them and we
began to model them
for our children
because children oftentimes
follow what we model better
than what we try to teach
verbally, they become you.
You become them.
And every time that you think,
that is what you think first.
And that is why I said these
ceremonies and rituals help
us to think of Mother
Earth before we
make bigger decisions about
our own health and welfare.
OK, now, when we think of being
made of the metals, minerals,
and liquids of Earth, we
tend to think that that
is what makes us human beings.
OK?
But that's just our human form.
It's actually the energy
that we get from the sun
that our ceremonies and
rituals are trying to direct.
OK?
And in Lakota, we believe
that that energy, that life,
that energy that is our
life force, our being,
if you can catch that--
it's what we are being--
is what that energy directs.
And in Lakota, we have our
own ways of looking at things.
That actual energy force
that is our being we think
is divided into four parts.
And in Lakota, this
would be like a map.
To the West, we consider
that part of our
being as spiritually based.
Another part to that
being is the emotion.
Another part is
intelligence, information.
The last part is physical.
Our being is connected
to all those four parts.
That energy, in our belief,
it is our environment
and how we model
our social awareness
and our personal awareness that
allows people to learn faster.
And if we sit them
in the classroom
and try to teach them the morals
and the values in a normal way
that we do this.
Throughout my relearning
Lakota ways of life--
and I spent a lot of time in
an environment where most of us
young Indian people
were doing this.
We were also involved in places
like going to the university,
having jobs in Western society.
And oftentimes, we
don't often think
of how those things influence
the way that we think,
reason, and behave.
And one of the things that I
discovered during that time
is that almost all
of this information
that Lakota people talk about
and other people talk about,
about spirituality, is known.
It's been reported on.
It's been documented.
It's been written.
But somehow, we've
been separated
from a lot of that information.
And even in Lakota,
we're finding
that a lot of information
that we use today, a lot of us
find that information
from reading.
A lot of us find
that information
from watching like this,
in different settings,
where somebody comes and they
teach us about certain things.
This is something
that is modern.
And in doing this
discovery, you find out
that there's a lot of
people along the way that
have had associations with
Indian people that have done
incredible studies and left
big bodies of information
behind them.
And while I was in college,
I studied psychology,
and I ran across a lot
of people that pointed me
in directions that
helped me learn how
to apply a lot of the cultural
activities and programs
that I do so that they were
more cultural in the design
and in the implementation,
the methodology.
One of these gentlemen
that I talk about,
or that I utilize some of his
theories, is Erik Erikson.
How many of you have heard
of him in psychology?
Erik Erikson, OK?
A few of you have.
Well, Erik Erikson was
of German heritage.
And he was a psychologist.
He came to America.
But one of the
things that he did
was that he studied in
Pine Ridge, South Dakota
on the Oglala
Lakota reservation.
He worked in an elders home.
And he did, of course, study
them as he was working there.
He's written several books
about those relationships.
One of the things
that he came up with
and that he is famous for is his
design of developmental stages
for human beings.
And he has eight of them that
he developed, all the way
from childhood to death.
That's all good.
In Lakota, we have four
basic developmental stages.
That's childhood, of course,
youth or young adult, adult,
and elders.
And like this, we believe that
there are, of course, birth,
all of those things are
covered on this medicine wheel
as well, the four different
developmental stages.
Along with learning and
studying Erik Erikson's work,
I also ran across a guy by
the name of Howard Gardner.
How many of you have
ever heard that name?
OK.
Now Howard Gardner
proposed the theory
of multiple intelligences.
And as Erik Erikson's
work kind of
aligned with the way
the Lakota believe
in developmental stages,
we, as Lakota people,
also realize, whether we call
them intelligences or not.
Sometimes we call them gifts.
Sometimes we call
them strong points.
But these intelligences,
we believe
that there are more than one
way of seeing and doing things,
understanding things.
The intelligences that
Howard Gardner came up with,
as we look at them across
developmental stages
from childhood to adulthood,
we start with interpersonal,
learning that relationship
between a mother and a baby.
That's very inter.
And about
intrapersonal, we learn
that as a very young child,
how we should behave.
Then we go into
bodily kinesthetics.
We all are familiar
with how kids learn how
to put things in their mouth.
Bodily kinesthetics,
how to do the things
that we do in a normal day.
Logical mathematical, that's
another type of intelligence
that Howard Gardner talked
about or believed in.
Then there was
linguistic intelligence.
And linguistic intelligence,
the Lakota people kind
of part a little bit
from this because we
believe that communication,
a lot of communication,
is nonverbal.
And we have
communication between
many, many different things
around us in our environment.
And I think you're aware
of some of those things.
I hope you are, and I'll talk
about a little bit of them
later on.
Another intelligence is musical.
We believe that there is
a musical intelligence,
a musical component.
And the last one is spatial.
And this is one that we get
to as adults, as elders.
And that's how things
actually fit together.
That's having a good idea of
what the macrocosm is about.
That's how we view spatial.
And one thing that we discover
also when we study psychology
is about behavior
management, or modification.
We all understand
what that is, right?
You got up this morning.
You came to work.
The first stop
sign you ran into,
that's behavior modification.
And I think a lot
of psychologists
spend a lot of hours
figuring out how to do that.
But that's what external
behavior modification is about.
Lakota culture,
as we look at it,
is a way of imparting
or instilling
internal behavior modification.
I would like to
explain a little bit
about how this is happening.
I'm going to use the example
of a stove, a hot stove, a wood
stove.
And you have a baby.
And the baby is
sitting on the floor.
The baby starts to
walk to the stove.
And the first thing,
the adult sees that.
He goes over there--
no, no, no, no,
no, no, it's hot.
And you bring him back.
You set him down.
Two seconds later, he
thinks it's a game.
He goes, ha, ha!
Parent-- no, no,
no, no, no, hot.
And we bring him back.
The example for the
Lakota lifestyle
is where he comes up there
and he touches the stove.
And as he touches the
stove, you say, no, no, hot.
That information has been
transferred to internal now.
And this is the kind of
practical application
of these cultural ways that
I am trying to talk about.
Now I'm ready to
sing the second song.
Lakota ceremony
and ritual is a way
that shows us how to fit
into this big macrocosm,
natural macrocosm.
So our prayer songs also
guide us along that way.
The song that I'm about to
sing is called the Mother Earth
Song.
And the gist of this song is
"Grandfather, the Creator,
I'm standing here.
Life is hard.
Help me.
Help me with my energy.
It is my purpose to
live with Mother Earth."
And as I told you before, it's
the ceremonies and rituals
of Lakota lifestyle
that from birth to life,
they control the way we learn
and the kind of information
we get through the
developmental stages.
But what they're
actually controlling
is those intelligences
that we have.
And when you think of
ceremonies and rituals,
they're not the actual
conditioning elements
that instill the behavior.
The actual rites that
I'm talking about,
the rites that
are what guide the whole nation.
There are many, many more
ceremonies and rituals
that are independent of the
small groups and the families
and individuals.
But there are seven
over-arcing ones
that have a goal and
that help us to be
who we are as Lakota people.
Of course, one of the
first ones would be Making
of Relatives, or a Hunkapi.
And that could be considered
as part of a naming ceremony
and an adoption
type of ceremony.
It's a making of relatives.
You have a new child come in.
Of course, you want to name it.
That's a part of what one of
these ceremonies is about.
And every developmental
stage that we enter into,
I would say the ages would
be 0 to 13, 13 into our 20s.
Then we become an adult,
20s into the whatever.
And then the
eldership at the end.
OK?
And that's kind of
how you look at it.
Next rites that we would
be involved in probably
on a communal level
as young people
would probably be the Inipi,
or purification ceremony,
especially for boys.
A long time ago, it used
to be a men-only ceremony.
And I think it's
changed in large part
over the years because of
not only indoctrination,
but assimilation to a
patriarchal society.
And a long time ago, women,
because of their moon,
the menstrual cycle, had a
way of purifying themselves.
At least, this is culturally
how we look at it.
And men did not.
And men needed one.
We needed a way to
make life as well.
This ceremony is also
considered at times
to be a way that we go.
We pray.
We re-energize ourselves.
We make life.
Women don't need that.
They're the only
part of our society,
the only ones within our
society, that can actually
create life.
Then you enter into that next--
we would call it
teens, young adults.
And those ceremonies that
impact us at that time for girls
would be Preparing a
Girl for Womanhood.
And that happens at their
first menstrual time.
The Throwing the Ball is
also associated with women.
But it's also more
of a social event
involving the whole community.
Hanblecheya used to be
a male-only ceremony.
It more involves both
women and men nowadays.
And it is what they say, like,
they are crying for a vision,
trying to figure out what our
purpose is spiritually in life.
OK?
And then we go to Wiwanyag
Wachipi, which is a sun dance.
It used to also be
a men-only ceremony.
And it's a
regeneration ceremony.
Think of the sun.
Our energy comes from the sun.
This is a specific ceremony
that is to regenerate us.
Now, all of these
seven ceremonies,
as you can see, just
as they describe,
they are about
giving us direction.
They are about
helping, guiding us
through our lives from
childhood up through adulthood.
And we believe that every one
of these sacred ceremonies
holds values and a morality
that is expected of a Lakota.
We do believe that.
And there is a specific
protocol and conduct involved
in each ceremony and each rite.
And of course, as children, in
participation in these things,
we learn that as we
go so that by the time
it comes to our time, it's
just elders instructing us.
And it's more of a rite.
We know what that
knowledge means now.
And in each one of these,
that's how that follows through.
We believe that the continued
usage of these ceremonies
and rites ensures not only
our commitment as individuals,
but our whole
society's commitment
to peaceful relationships
and being good relatives.
And that's very, very
important to Lakota people.
Kabilesi, our commitment,
is not what we talk about.
And it's not what we say.
But it's what we do in Lakota.
And to see our commitment
to this philosophy,
to this way of life, you can
see these types of commitments
through the preservation
of Earth, which
for us includes almost every
environmental issue that you
can think of, but
most recently, issues
over clean water, and for us,
food sovereignty, conservation,
appropriate farming, and
animal husbandry practices.
And this type of commitment,
it extends into everything
that we do, whether we're
putting in a water filtration
plant, or whether we're
manning and maintaining
a protest in Standing Rock.
That fundamental
values and stuff
is what drives all
of those things.
I'm going to sing
the third song now.
And it's a healing song.
And think about all the
things I've been telling you.
As Lakota people, this
song is very simple.
It says, "Grandfather"--
or God, as you would say--
"help me with my energy.
I'm doing this so I can live."
And I don't know how many of
you have followed Standing Rock.
But that's the core
of that message.
We're not doing
this for notoriety.
this for extra cash.
Man, made of the metals,
minerals, and liquids
of Earth-- we need that liquid.
We need that clean water.
And I won't go any
more into that.
I think you guys get it.
So as I think this
third song afterwards,
I'm going to go into a little
bit about how that commitment
looks in Rosebud.
Now, the commitments
that we have in
Rosebud towards
these things that I
was talking to you about--
clean water, food sovereignty,
conservation.
There's so many words
we can use to describe
that, appropriate
farming techniques, all
of those things--
are primarily missed
by my generation.
And I'll tell you.
OK?
I'm going explain
to you a little bit
how that could happen.
My generation, there was more of
an impetus by the governments,
by everybody, powers that
be, to still separate us
from our roots, which is,
of course, the reservation.
Part of that process
was to come out here,
out into Western society,
and to develop a career,
to learn a trade, to do
those kind of things.
Now, there's one way
of looking at this.
Historically, we can say, that
was just such a terrible thing
for those white people to do.
And I would say, yes,
it was something that
should have never happened.
But it did happen.
And we can't take it back.
We can't change it.
And it goes back to that same
old thing that a lot of people
say-- when life gives you
lemons, what do you do?
Well, what did I do?
I fell in love
with a nice woman.
We had children. .
And I realized that in
order to make lemons,
I had to go to school.
And it's those kind
of things that I
came to believe in in myself
that I began to pursue,
knowing full well that I
didn't fit, blah, blah, blah.
I wasn't a part of,
blah, blah, blah.
But the big thing
about it is, I didn't
realize until much later,
is that I picked up
a lot of good skills.
And I picked up part of this
what I'm talking to you about--
innovation and
scientific thinking.
I'm saying that's a part
of Lakota thinking too.
But it's more refined out here.
And those things
really helped me.
Because if you think about
this culture and rituals,
before colonization,
there was no need
to teach this like this.
We just did it as a
part of the natural way
of getting up every day
and going through life.
The skills and the things
that I picked up out
in Western society are
appropriate for this time.
There's no way we can go back
and have the pristine natural
and live that way.
We're going to have to
deconstruct, re-engineer.
There's a lot of
things like that
that we're going to have to do.
And they're like, you
need the innovation
and the scientific thinking.
And if you think
about your history,
I'm sure that it's
very similar to mine
if you go back far enough.
And I'm saying we're
all re-engineering
and deconstructing
at this point.
We feel that?
We're all in this together.
Now a couple of the things--
I'm not going to cover a
lot of different projects
that we're doing.
But I'm going to try
to stay in and show you
how who we are as human beings,
the culture and the traditions,
actually looks like on
the far end, on the end we
want to be in.
[LAUGHS]
And I'm going to use Three
Sisters Gardening, one
of the techniques.
How many of you
have heard of that?
If you grew up in New
York, you've heard of that.
And the other one, I'm going
to use an example, somewhat
of an example.
I'm going to compare
cows and buffalo.
Buffalo are traditional
animals where I come from.
We can't own Three Sisters
Gardening because we learned
that from somewhere else.
But we have other plants.
If you look at Three
Sisters Gardening in a way
as being a way of
companion planting,
plants that help
each other to grow--
and I'll explain
that a little bit.
We use three sisters as
corn, beans, and squash.
Corn grows up.
There's a stalk.
You plant the beans.
The beans crawl the stalk.
And the squash,
the large plants,
cover a large area of ground.
At least, this is theory.
Unless you've actually
done it, you'll
find there's a lot of other
things involved in that.
But the big leaves of the
squash keep the moisture
in the ground, as well as
keeping the other plants
from growing too fast.
Now, there are a lot
of nuances to this.
OK?
And it's those
things, we just don't
want to look at it as
companion planting.
When we look at that, we
have to see as we're doing,
how it's putting something
back into the Earth.
Because we're giving
back to Mother Earth.
We're brothers and
sisters with the plant.
We got our metals,
minerals, and liquids.
All forms are from the metals,
minerals, liquids of the Earth.
And everything gets its
energy from the sun.
So we basically follow
the same patterns of life.
We take from the Earth.
And then somehow we
give back to the Earth.
In respect to the Three
Sisters Gardening,
beans return nitrogen
to the Earth.
And one thing that
I know at home,
with the introduction
of cattle, cattle
are not traditional to
the land where I'm from.
And they go out
there a lot of times,
and they eat the wrong plants.
And they die.
Cattle can do that.
And buffalo from where I'm
from, they go out there
and they know how to eat.
They know the difference.
And they're also not as
invasive to the land.
It has to do with the way
that their hooves are made
and how they go through.
They eat.
When they eat, buffaloes will
eat from the top of the grass.
Cows will go all the
way down to the roots
and pull the roots out.
That's just a difference.
It's just a difference.
OK?
And buffalo, the
way that they're
made, if you look at them,
they're natural seeders.
Man, they take the
seed off the grass,
and they can take it
for miles and miles.
There's just a lot of different
things, as you study them,
that you can see that
they're more indigenous.
They fit in with the land.
That commitment that
I was talking about,
that comes from these
ceremonies and rituals,
were missed in my generation.
But now, the next generation
is coming through,
and they're picking it up.
It's very important
to them right now.
Standing Rock, the
issues at Standing Rock,
were first confronted
by women and by youth.
And that's a shift that
we're going through now.
OK?
And that's all the more
I have to say about that.
The other part to the Three
Sisters Gardening I want to say
is that each part
of the plant is
assigned a specific
role from the root,
stems, leaves, et cetera.
And we believe that it is
imbued with deep cultural--
it is understanding and
meaning and plays a big role
in our ceremonies and
rituals, especially when it
comes to healing.
I've got a couple of examples to
help people to understand that.
And I'm going to use the example
of honey and anti-histamines
and allergies.
And Lakota people, we believe
that spirit comes from place.
And what that means is if you
have allergies, the bees that
go all around the area
that you're living,
they collect all
of this nice stuff
that they put into this
thing they call honey.
But everything that they
go around and gather,
all of that nice stuff that
they put into that honey,
is the very stuff that you need
to build up your immune system.
Everybody get the gist of that?
And that's not trying
to be over vague.
But some of this stuff is better
when you think it out yourself.
Everybody understand that?
I'm just kind of dropping
a little seed in there.
OK?
As long as you understand that.
Now, why would I come here?
And why would I
talk to all of you?
I recognize that a lot of
this cultural knowledge,
like I said, it's printed.
We've documented it.
It's out there.
But we're the same
way as you in the fact
that a lot of that
information gets put somewhere
in our busy lives.
We don't have the
time, energy maybe.
There's a lot of things involved
to really pursue and to upgrade
and to update to
that information.
It's common.
It happens all the time.
But like, you we Lakotas have
realized that we either do this
or we die.
We're kind of at a
tipping point where
we can't let it go any longer.
And I'm not really good at
being scary because I'm always
trying to help people
from being scared.
So I'm not-- but I don't
know how many of you
feel real tense at this
time, not really knowing
how it's going to go.
You feel like some bad
things could happen,
but you're not really--
do we have time?
Can we really save ourselves?
I think we're all at that way.
The only answer
to that in Lakota
is that would become
connected again,
not only to Mother
Earth, but to each other.
How do we do that?
In Lakota, if we would have
done this really ceremonial when
I came in here, I would have
shook each one of your hands.
We would have shook
each other's hands.
That's a physical connection.
We would have looked each other
in the eye and said hello.
Who are you?
I'm so-and-so.
That's how you connect.
And this is what I'm
trying to do out here.
I'm trying to bring that
understanding that I have.
And it's my commitment
to these things.
I'm trying to encourage.
I know there's a lot of people
doing a lot of good things.
I found that out since I
came here to Santa Cruz.
And there's a lot of people that
really got their heads screwed
on pretty good.
When you're in my bubble in
Rosebud, we don't know that.
Now you see why I'm trying
to make connections.
And I'm hoping--
I know that I come out
here and talk to people.
And people say, oh, what's
going on in Standing Rock?
What's going on
in Standing Rock?
I said, do you even
know who we are?
Do you even know why
we're doing things?
And I said, I'm thinking
that because I'm
coming from a lot of years
of conditioned understanding
of how we get treated
and how we get talked to
and how we get talked about.
So the first thing I
want to do is come out
and say, this so we are.
This is a little bit more about
who we are and how it works.
And it's not like it's so great
and so hard to understand,
because it isn't.
It's very simple.
How many of you agree
with me that with me?
It is.
And so from the very
beginning, shake your hand.
This is connection.
Looking at each other,
that's connection.
I know how many of
you walk around,
you don't want to connect.
That's our society
that does that.
That's not us.
We're social.
Get around animals, horses.
They'll show you
how social happens.
That's why we say,
to be out with nature
and to be around nature
shows us so much.
OK, I'm going to
sing the last song.
And then we will have a
question and answer, I guess.
This last song is something
that we also teach ourselves
that we have to be, thankful.
This song is thanking
you, thanking everything.
"Thank you for the
life you have given me"
is basically the words
that are being said.
How many there heard of
Wounded Knee, the first one?
It was a bad day, right?
That happened in
December of 1890.
In November of 1890,
Ohio State University
played its first football game.
That kind of puts
in time perspective.
So 127 years ago, that's
what we looked like.
That's how we dressed.
That's how we
conducted ourselves.
127 years ago,
believe it or not,
we were on horseback,
living in teepees,
chasing buffalo
across the prairie.
That was the last of it.
That was when it ended.
AUDIENCE: Two
questions actually.
First one is when you were taken
from your biological parents,
did they ever visit you?
Could they visit you?
Or did you go back to see them?
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: I
reunited with my family,
a part of my family, in 1976.
It was like 12, 13
years afterwards.
So for me, my being
separated from my family
was not as long as some people.
Now, when you go through
the adoption process
as an American Indian--
and I think this is
nationwide to everybody-- they
seal your court records, all.
So that cuts you off effectively
from being able to get back.
And this is where--
not to be political, or
not to get out of bounds,
but so that we understand.
This is where a lot of
American Indian people
look at the adoption
process and say
that it was an act of genocide.
They moved us from our people
to a totally different culture,
cut off all connections back.
And some people like
to say it's cultural.
We say, well, what about all
those people that got out here
and they couldn't live
because they had nobody there
to help them?
AUDIENCE: You talked
about the whole focus is
on teaching people to be good--
good allies, good
friends, and good family.
What do you do to
make things just?
When somebody veers off
or things don't go well,
how do you make things just?
How do you do justice?
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER:
Well, first of all,
our system works differently.
Rather than having
a group of people
where you have a few
people on the outside that
are exerting external control,
justice doesn't really
happen the same way.
When you have a group of people
where everything is internally
built on the same principles,
the same values, those type
of things, over
a period of time,
and you always have
mentors, you always
have people that are
coaching, always having
people that are helping--
because that's the whole
purpose of the community.
Then you have less problems
of lack of justice.
We work on the same things
that everybody else works on--
jealousies, low self-esteem.
But our culture, our
rites, our ways of life
are directed to
building relationships
that that's minimized.
OK?
That's a part of the
plan, so to speak.
OK?
And whether those things
were handed down from God,
or whether over hundreds
and hundreds of years,
we just realized, don't
touch that hot stove,
those things came to be.
And as they exist today,
because it's only 127 years ago,
we still have memories, and we
still have ties to those ways.
AUDIENCE: How long ago was
it that the law changed
that they can no longer adopt
children who are Indian?
I've forgotten the name of
the law, Indian Welfare Act?
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER:
Indian Child Welfare Act.
AUDIENCE: Indian
Child Welfare Act.
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: I believe
it happened in the '80s.
I know that the American
Indian Religious Freedom
Act happened in 1978,
the ability to practice
our religions again.
And I'm not really positive.
I'm just taking a guess that
it happened in the '80s.
AUDIENCE: The important thing
is not when, but it did happen.
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So now that
doesn't continue.
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: It happened.
And it's like so
many laws that they
passed for the majority of us.
It has no teeth.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us, when we
you were repatriated
to the Lakota at what
seemed like around 19
or 20 years of age,
how difficult was it for you
to relearn all of the history
and tradition?
How much had you remembered
from your childhood?
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: I was
taken at four years old.
I was able to speak
as a four-year-old.
You're going to have to
all decide what that was.
Why IronEagleFeather
Project exists today
is because that journey home
is particularly arduous.
And there is no help.
And when you think about you're
to support yourself and live
your life, that
oppression, you're
having to hold it up when you're
building something down here,
everything gets twisted.
So what we're trying to
do is to create a way
to make that journey
back because when
this stuff happened to create
the world we have right now,
nobody had any idea that
it was going to happen
and that we were going to need
to have these kind of things
in the future.
I think people actually thought
they were building something
better.
Unfortunately, as we know now,
they were a little misguided.
And we're going to
have to redo it.
And that's what IronEagleFeather
is already assuming
is that there won't be anybody
there to give us a hand.
This is a on-your-own
kind of thing.
Does that makes sense?
Because it is our culture.
I don't mind it.
I'm willing to do double
time, overtime for this.
Anyway, does that kind
of answer your question?
IronEagleFeather exists because
that is particularly hard.
AUDIENCE: That point
you made around the need
to connect and connect
authentically, person
to person, really
struck a chord.
I was just curious.
In your own journey,
what would you
say is one of the most powerful
or meaningful connections
you've made with someone
that you wouldn't maybe
have otherwise come to know,
or a connection that you've
seen made between two people
that wouldn't have necessarily
happened without a lot
of intentional effort?
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: For me, the
best tools, the best ceremony
and rites that I went through
were the sweat lodge and sun
dance.
They did the most for me.
But actually, the most
gut-wrenching mind-bending,
freeing experience
that I went through
was when I reunited with my mom.
And I can't--
I mean it, would
take me forever.
And the relationship, it's
not like everybody else has
a relationship with their mom.
In fact, there was
those years where
we didn't know who we were.
So we didn't develop that
bonding kind of a thing
beyond the age of
four years old.
But when I reconnected to that,
something about the energy.
That's as far as I
can go with that.
I can't really explain it.
But those other
ceremonies and rituals
helped me to deal with that,
helped me to understand.
It helped me to direct
that energy back
into things that were
productive other than my hurt,
my low self-esteems,
all the things
that I went through while
I was away from my mother.
So in a way, just that meeting
her with those other ceremonies
helped me to bring
me back into balance.
AUDIENCE: I've heard a little
bit about the communication
style between the Western
culture and the Indian culture
and how it's like a 180 flip
of way of thinking about it.
And I just wonder what
your take was on that.
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER: You're right.
In a lot of
instances, it doesn't
matter what we're
talking about, when
Lakota people talk about it
and non-Lakota people hear it,
oftentimes, they assume
that we mean a lot of things
that we don't with what we say.
And the big thing is, as
I told you, in Lakota,
somehow we get the
idea that there
are four parts to our energy.
And the spiritual
part is a big part
that isn't included out here.
And we always speak
with that part in mind.
So the miscommunication
could happen
from a society that doesn't
involve that in the way
that they speak and
the way that they hear.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's good.
LEVI EAGLEFEATHER:
And this is what
I'm assuming because I can't
draw any direct correlation
of how that actually unfolds.
I'm more involved in catching
people who are really hurting
or who really need help
and trying to redirect.
I hope you're following me.
Rather than trying to correct
that thing that we think
differently, I'm
trying to work with it,
if that makes any sense.
I thank all of you.
[APPLAUSE]